This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
From BBC Learning English
Hello, this is 6 Minute English, I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
It's good to see you again, Sam.
Really?
Yeah, of course.
Can't you tell by the way I'm smiling?
Well, I find it difficult to tell if someone is really smiling
or if it's a fake smile.
Well, that's a coincidence because this programme
is all about how computers may be able to tell real smiles
from fake smiles better than humans can.
Before we get into that, though, a question.
The expressions that we can make with our face are controlled by muscles.
How many muscles do we have in our face?
Is it a 26, b 43 or c 62?
What do you think, Sam?
No idea, but a lot, I'd guess.
So I'm going with 62.
OK, well, we'll see if you'll be smiling
or crying later in the programme.
Hassan Ugael is a professor of visual computing
at the University of Bradford.
He's been working on getting computers
to be able to recognise human emotions
from the expressions on our face.
Here he is speaking on the BBC Inside Science Radio programme.
How successful does he say they have been?
We've been working quite a lot on the human emotions
or the ideas how the facial muscle movement
which is reflected on the face,
through obviously computer, through video frames,
and trying to understand how these muscle movements
actually relate to facial expressions
and then from facial expressions,
trying to understand the emotions or to infer the emotions.
And we have been quite successful in doing that.
We have software that can actually look at somebody's face
in real time and then identify the series of emotions
that persons express in real time as well.
So, have they been successful in getting computers
to identify emotions?
Yes, he says they've been quite successful.
And what's interesting is that he says
that the computers can do it in real time.
This means that there's no delay.
They don't have to stop and analyse the data
or crunch the numbers.
They can do it as the person is talking.
The system uses video to analyse a person's expressions
and can then infer the emotions.
To infer something means to get an understanding of something
without actually being told directly.
So, you look at available information
and use your understanding and knowledge
to work out the meaning.
It's a bit like being a detective, isn't it?
You look at the clues and infer what happened
even if you don't have all the details.
Yes, and in this case, the computer looks
at how the movement of muscles in the face
or facial muscles show different emotions.
Here's Professor Ugeh again.
We've been working quite a lot on the human emotions
or the idea is how the facial muscle movement
which is reflected on the face
through obviously computer through video frames
and trying to understand how these muscle movements
actually relate to facial expressions
and then from facial expressions
trying to understand the emotions
or to infer the emotions.
And we have been quite successful in doing that.
We have software that can actually look at somebody's face
in real time and then identify the series of emotions
that person is expressing in real time as well.
So, how do the computers know what is a real or a fake smile?
The computers have to learn that first.
Here's Professor Ugeh again talking about how they do that.
We have a data set of real smiles
and we have a data set of fake smiles.
These real smiles are indeed smiles in a lab.
So, you put somebody on the chair
and then show some funny movies
and we expect the smiles are genuine smiles.
And similarly, we ask them to pretend they're smile
so these are what we call fake smiles.
So, what we do is we throw these into the machine
and then the machine figures out
what are the characteristics of a real smile
and what are the characteristics of a fake smile.
So, how do they get the data that the computers use
to see if your smile is fake or genuine,
which is another word which means real?
They induce real smiles in the lab
by showing people funny films.
This means that they make the smiles come naturally.
They assume that the smiles while watching the funny films are genuine.
And then they ask the people to pretend to smile
and the computer programme now has a database of real and fake smiles
and is able to figure out which is which.
Figure out means to calculate and come to an answer.
Yes and apparently the system gets it right 90% of the time
which is much higher than we humans can.
Right, well, before we remind ourselves of our vocabulary,
let's get the answer to the question.
How many muscles do we have in our face?
Is it A, 26, B, 43 or C, 62?
Sam, are you going to be smiling?
What did you say?
Aha, so I thought 62.
Am I smiling, Neil?
Sadly, you are not using different muscles for that sort of sad look.
Actually, the answer is 43.
Congratulations to anyone who got that right.
Now our vocabulary.
Yes, so facial is the adjective relating to face.
Then we had infer.
This verb means to understand something even when you don't have all the information
and you come to this understanding based on your experience and knowledge
or in the case of a computer, the programming.
And these computers work in real time which means that there's no delay
and they can tell a fake smile from a genuine one,
which means a real one, as the person is speaking.
They made people smile or, as the professor said,
they induced smiles by showing funny films.
And the computer is able to figure out or calculate whether the smile is fake or genuine.
Okay, thank you, Sam.
That's all from six minute English today.
We look forward to your company next time.
And if you can't wait, you can find lots more from BBC Learning English online
on social media and on our app.
Goodbye.
Bye-bye.
From BBC Learning English.